[Musique]
député les républicains des yvelines
également conseiller départemental dont
ce département si amère de bois d'arcy
philippe benassaya l'invité de
l'entretien politique bonjour bonjour vu
sur ce plateau merci d'avoir accepté
cette invitation merci également aux
téléspectateurs qui nous suivent on va
parler avec vous de cette commission
d'enquêté parlementaire sur les
dysfonctionnements et manquements de la
politique pénitentiaire française
commission que vous présidez depuis
quelques semaines maintenant auparavant
quelques sujets sur lesquels vous faire
réagir de politique actuellement le
premier concerne la présidentielle on en
parle beaucoup au niveau national votre
famille politique hésite encore entre un
congrès pour désigner le candidat ou une
primaire donc pour désigner son ou sa
candidate d'ailleurs le 25 septembre les
adhérents vont devoir trancher quel est
votre choix faut-il passer par le
congrès ou organiser directement une
primaire alors personnellement je suis
plutôt favorable passer par un congrès
et faire voter des militants militants
adhérents militants et leurs
sympathisants et l'air je connais pas
trop là la précision d'état je pense que
les primaires en français sur une
machine à perdre d'autant plus qu'il y a
des gens qui ne sont pas du tout de
votre bord politique et qui vient de
voter pour faire blocage pour favoriser
un autre candidat donc on se retrouve
souvent prisonniers d'un vote qui n'est
pas celui de votre propre famille
politique les primaires et sont issus
d'une une idée de la démocratie
participative qui était très en vogue
dans les années 2000 2010 et qui
aujourd'hui je pense n'est pas n'est pas
adapté alors certes on n'a pas de
candidat naturel
aujourd'hui chez les l'air ce qui nous
change beaucoup puisque à droite on a
toujours eu un chef qui incarnait
vraiment l'endroit qui a incarné le
droite quoi qu'on en pense fillon était
un candidat naturel quoi qu'on en pense
sarkozy chirac
pompidou enfin bref quand on monte
jusqu'à jusqu'au général de gaulle
jusqu'à bien sûr non là là les temps ont
changé
peut-être aussi la faute à la photo
numérique la faute à la communication
rapide la photo fait que maintenant les
choses ne se passent pas comme avant
enfin plus de buzz immédiat que de
vraiment de s'installer dans la
continuité construire une image
politique présidentiable en tout cas sa
végétation sur la durée on zappe
beaucoup et au sein des familles
politiques aux abois mais c est votre
candidat copie que vous l'avez déjà
antenne vraiment non alors c'est pas du
tout de la langue de bois puisqu'on en
parle et même avant la vente avant ce
cette émission difficile de faire le
choix quand on n'a pas un candidat
naturel ils se valent tous ils ont tous
des qualités c'est très compliqué à
choisir comment départager xavier
bertrand d'un michel barnier qui ont vu
leur expérience valérie pécresse d'un
exode qui figure dans tous tes qualités
je sais pas je pense que ça se fera au
dernier moment au feeling la proposition
qui fera tilt à la au dernier moment
mais l'a pour l'instant c'est compliqué
et quand vous voyez quand vous lisez
dans la presse encore aujourd'hui que
karl olive soutient ouvertement emmanuel
macron le maire de poissy manger le plus
tôt je suis plutôt ancien très anciens
élèves
je suis plutôt soulagé pour lui c'est à
dire que en politique
l'objectif ce n'est pas de
de jouer dans les deux camps c'est de
choisir son équipe moi je les choisis
depuis l'âge de 16 ans lui il a choisi
aujourd'hui c'est très bien et tant
mieux pour lui je pense qu'il sera
soulagé aussi d'être plus cohérent plus
transparents et est plus franc avec ses
idées ses valeurs et ses électeurs ses
administrés aussi je pense que c'est une
bonne chose pour lui en tout cas ne vous
parler d'être plus clair aussi pour les
électeurs je reviens la politique locale
du côté de trappes il ya des élections
élections municipales partielles il ya
une invalidation de ce scrutin en juin
par le conseil d'état mer pendant 19 ans
battu la dernière fois guy malandain lui
fait à lyon cette fois ci avec un membre
de votre parti ottomane mastrou je
proposais kutiman à souhait vous fait
réagir juste après c'est pas une
histoire de droite ou de gauche c'est
une histoire de sauver les valeurs de la
république dans la gestion de la mairie
on est en train de sombrer dans la
division dans le clientélisme il faut
tourner cette page là et donc le soutien
de guy malandain il est tout à fait
nécessaire il est tout à fait salutaire
chacun lui reconnaît sa stature son
expérience son humanité je ne lui ai
jamais contesté on a eu des divergences
sur tel ou tel sujet entre temps
beaucoup de choses se sont passées on a
appris à se connaître et il va
m'apporter je l'espère son expérience
aussi lui qui a été aux commandes de
notre vie pendant 20 ans à laquelle il a
consacré 20 années de sa fille mais je
le dis c'est un front républicain
votre mana fro qui parle de front
républicain tout comme guy malandain
deux anciens ennemis de deux bords
politiques aujourd'hui alliés pour faire
face à gênés au candidat génération à
mirabel votre avis alors c'est votre
circonscription je le précise aussi que
c'est sur un rap est une très grande
ville de ma circonscription faudrait
savoir ce qu'on veut aux municipales on
dit toujours la politique n'est pas
la priorité c'est le rassemblement des
talents c'est faire gagner un projet
c'est voilà on y est pour une fois qu'on
fait pas de la politique politicienne on
y est guy malandain qui a été maire de
trappes et autres magnats seront ont
décidé de se rassembler pour faire
barrage à une conception qui n'est pas
forcément la conception que nous avons
nous à droite et peut-être même à gauche
du malandain de la république de la
laïcité et du vivre ensemble c'est leur
conception et c'est pour ça qu'ils se
sont ralliés moi j'ai fait du
rassemblement aussi quand j'étais à
bonnart 6 il faut savoir rassembler les
talents il faut savoir a semblé aussi
les compétences il faut il faut aussi
sortir c'est vrai que tu rappelles
mauvaise image aujourd'hui alors que
c'est injuste parce qu'il ya aussi une
ville qui réussit des entreprises qui
réussissent à trappes je suis tout le
temps sur le terrain trappe de visite
des fleurons de l'industrie française il
y a deux trappes et je pense que avec
nas rouet et malanda on peut avoir un
trappe ou une trappe qui qui réussissent
et qui est qu'ils puissent tourner la
page un petit peu de la polémique et des
des violences verbales et le scrutin ce
sera le 10 et 17 octobre jean vient
votre nomination dans le cadre de vos
fonctions de député à la tête de cette
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
les dysfonctionnements les manquements
de la politique pénitentiaire française
un sujet d'envergure peut dresser
peut-être un état des lieux aujourd'hui
dans quel état se trouvent les prisons
alors je vais commencer par une anecdote
et puis je vous ai je veux répondre à
votre question en général le 31 décembre
lorsque les politiques se déplacent ils
vont toujours dans un commissariat ils
vont toujours dans une caserne de
pompiers gendarmes qui est très bien
jamais un sens pénitentiaire je pense
que la prison est parfois le parent
pauvre de la société française parent
pauvre qui rassemble tous les problèmes
de la société française
la personne à pénitentiaire mal reconnus
souvent mal payés des problèmes de
logement au tour du personnel
pénitentiaire des flingueurs allie des
qualités pour l'hebdo monnerie problème
de rénovation problème de place il ya
soixante un peu plus de soixante mille
détenus en france aujourd'hui il y en
aura probablement 70000 dans quelques
années on n'est pas combien de places
jeu il ne manque entre quinze et vingt
mille places de prison c'est c'est grave
d'autant plus qu'il faut savoir que une
place de prison en france c'est entre
200 et 300 mille euros la place vous
voyez quand vous faites l'addition si
vous êtes 15000 et 20000 places en plus
on se chiffrent en centaines de millions
voire un milliard de milliards donc la
prison est vraiment le parent pauvre et
ensuite
doit faire face à tous les problèmes de
la société aujourd'hui et la commission
d'enquêté parlementaire a fait pour ça
le député doit contrôler les politiques
publiques et il doit surtout faire des
enquêtes commission d'un plaid parlement
ont fait des enquêtes c'est à dire qu'on
interroge les acteurs principaux des du
l'univers pénitentiaire pour savoir ce
qu'il ce qui dysfonctionne et ce qui
fonctionne mon impression en plus à vous
écouter vous le confirmer qu'il ya
énormément dysfonctionnement par souvent
de surpopulation carcérale mais
effectivement vous l'avais dit à la
règle localisation le problème du
personnel aussi pour encadrer tous ces
détenus au final est-ce que vous aurez
assez de temps pour mener cette
commission parce que le mandat
n'oublions pas que les prochaines
élections législatives vont se dérouler
l'année prochaine et puis au delà de ça
très bien on fait un état des lieux et
ensuite parce que ces dysfonctionnements
certes on les connaît peut-être pas le
détail mais on sait très bien qu'il y en
a les cours européennes ont déjà épinglé
à plusieurs reprises la france sur ces
sujets là par exemple donc quelle
finalité vous avez raison d'avoir déjà
juste à ce chiffre en maison d'arrêt ils
ont arrêté des petites peines et les
préventive il ya 140 % de surpopulation
c'est à dire qu'il y à beaucoup plus de
2,2 de détenus que de que de places de
prison on est on est face à des à des
situations dramatiques des gens il ya
des détenus qui dorment sur des matelas
à gariane nord mais il ya des milliers
de matelas dans l'est dans les cellules
française je vous rappelle wilfrid qu'il
y ait une loi en 2000 une loi française
qui oblige l'encellulement individuel
encellulement individuel qui n'est pas
respectée faute de place vous voyez au
cumul beaucoup de problèmes alors on a
quatre cinq mois devant nous pour
pouvoir auditionner tout le monde
associations syndicats ministre
ministères organismes publics pour pour
essayer de sortir une sorte de livre
blanc et qui nous permet de faire des
propositions dans l émir le timing est
mauvais c'est pas mal c'est le président
de l'assemblée nationale mais c'est vrai
que on est face à une situation
politique un peu sensible puisque on va
rendre nos travaux tout en plus que moi
je fus présent la commission des
requêtes est que ma rapporteur et député
de la majorité donc c'est toujours le
petit jeu parlementaire on essaie
d'épicés d'épicés les problèmes on est
on est jamais simple donc qui aurait
essayé de faire des propositions on a
décidé elle et moi sept députés en
marche et moi de faire vraiment un
travail objectif sincère parce qu'on a
vraiment l émoi le le souci de sortir
les prisons de l'ornière l'impasse dans
laquelle elle se trouve aujourd'hui il
ya beaucoup de problèmes je les dis ah
les problèmes de rénovation prison du
plan sont très vétustes celle de bois
d'arcy et très vite us par exemple
celles de poissy ou celles de poissy la
prison des femmes de versailles il ya
énormément sujet je visite énormément de
prison j'ai visité 25 prison d'un an ce
qu'est ce qui est beaucoup et je fais
toujours le même constat vous avez soit
des prisons extrêmement vétustes
centre-ville ça les prisons modernes
hors les murs comme on dit comme à
draguignan à mont de marsan où ce sont
des prisons 2.0 c'est à dire que les
détenus sont en liberté dans la prison
il faut leur potager il faut leur ils
font leur sport etc donc on est face à
deux de sujets sert qu'on a une vétusté
et à la fin une modernisation des
prisons ce qu'a fait le gouvernement
depuis cinq ans est insuffisant ils ont
fait 2000 places de prison peu près
entre 1700 et 2000 places de prison ce
qui est largement suffisant par rapport
aux promesses du candidat du candidat
macro donc il nous faut entre 15000 et
20000 places du pays il faut les faire
parce que et puis il faut aussi revoir
les peines il faudra voir si la durée
des peines et la question vous avez vous
posé aujourd'hui alors vous êtes encore
en commission denquête cette étude met
votre point de vue déjà en tant que
responsable politique en tant que député
ce serait plus de places de prison mais
il faut du budget pour le faire il
faudrait des peines aménagées ses terres
facilement on va dire si ce point ne pas
systématiser les peines de prisons
hôpitaux des peines à domicile par
exemple des choses comme ça un bracelet
ionique par exemple des peines les
peines qui sont en dessous de 6 à 8 mois
sont inutiles pourquoi parce que le
parcours pour intégrer un détenu
s'est plus de six mois ça sert à rien le
jour le jour ils commencent à être
intégrés
donc ça c'est le premier problème il ya
le problème des brosses électriques qui
règle pas tout on a eu un problème du du
détenu qui s'était réfugié dans une
forêt en dordogne à quelques mois je
sais vous souvenez il avait un bracelet
électronique c'est pas pour autant qu'il
n'a pas
intérêt c'est fait donc il y à il ya
beaucoup sujet il ya les problèmes de la
rénovation il ya un problème de la
radicalité il ya beaucoup de sujets en
prison qui pose problème et puis il ya
aussi le problème des détenus étrangers
on va mettre les pieds dans le plat les
détenus étrangers qui font des pins en
france c'est très bien mais qu'est ce
qu'on en fait après ce qu'il faut les
renvoyer dans leur pays d'origine après
tout ils ont purgé la peine en france
parce qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait des
méfaits en france mais aussi des ce
qu'il faut les renvoyer ce qu'il faut
les garder c'est une vraie question
politique très médiatique s'cusez moi
très touchy sur justement vous avez un
avis sur cette question moi j'ai fait
plusieurs l'a résumé ah oui ou non parce
que c'est possible mêlant d'une
commission denquête donc je dois faire
attention à ce que je dis aussi plus
d'accord mais personnellement c'est vrai
que je trouve ça un petit peu incohérent
qu'un détenus étrangers restent
emprisonnés et condamnés restent sur
territoire français maintenant la
commission denquête jugera et donc on
verra ce que nous dirons tous les tous
les acteurs de cette commission denquête
il ya bien d'autres sujets il ya les
quartiers semi liberté il ya énormément
de sujets il y allait aussi n'oubliez
pas les centres de détention pour
mineurs il y avait aussi ces sujets là
donc vous voyez c'est un sujet j'ai dit
5 6 mois mais on fera
fera pas tout mais on essaiera au moins
de dégager des pistes pour faire des
propositions concrètes c'est justement
pour faire que soient les candidats
d'ailleurs oui pour faire des
propositions concrètes justement vous
attendez vous souhaitez que ce soit un
enjeu aussi de la prochaine élection
présidentielle lorsque alors c'est vrai
on parle beaucoup surpopulation et
autres mets radicalisation c'est revenue
plusieurs fois et on le sait c'est
toujours dans cette actualité là et
aujourd'hui les débats politiques
portent beaucoup autour de cette
question là aussi donc le azur bien sûr
non mais encore une fois puisque c'est
le parent pauvre de la république il est
temps de sensibiliser les candidats la
république le prochain président ou la
prochaine présidente il faut
les sensibiliser à cette question là
tous les problèmes de société sont
concentrés dans un même lieu voilà les
problèmes à la fois je vous dédie de
logements de rénovation de radicalité
d'aumônerie de deux d'avancement de
grade de salaire de logement je tiens à
vous préciser que les petits jeunes j'ai
zappé les petits jeunes puisque je les
connais des jeunes qui sortent des
concours et qui arrive en maison d'arrêt
ans en détention ou en voilà qui souvent
ne trouve pas de peu de logements pour
se loger ils dorment dans leur voiture
donc il y à tous les sujets qui sont
concentrées faut vraiment aujourd'hui
prendre à bras le corps ce sujet d'abord
parce que ça touche la sécurité ça
touche aussi la justice comment sont
respectées les
coordonnées ci avait fait exécuter
derrière et l'enseignement qui est
derrière ça fonctionne un fils d un
fonctionnement vous voyez qu'on touche
on est à à l'intersection de plusieurs
de plusieurs sujets et de plusieurs
ministères merci beaucoup le député des
yvelines d'être venu nous parler de ses
parutions et vous reviendrez avant la
fin de votre mandat pour pour en faire
un bilan justement et on se retrouve
bientôt sur tv soixante dix huit pour un
nouvel entretien politique
[Musique]